If you're the host of the discussion, and there are participants who are new to you,...
...you should definitely introduce yourself at the beginning.
The same is true for anyone who may be presenting, speaking,...
...or contributing significantly to the discussion.
Because it's important to get right to the agenda,...
...you want to make sure that the introductions are quick and concise.
So, here are two simple formulas to help you do that.
If you're hosting a professional meeting, you could use something like,...
"Hi, everyone. I'm Annemarie, the director of Speak Confident English...
...and I'll be your host for the discussion today."
Or "Good morning, everyone. I'm Lina,...
I'm a junior analyst at KPMG and I'll be leading the discussion today."
Do you notice in both of those,...
...I'm including the name, the title or job position...
...and the organization where someone works.